Speaker 1: . Hey, this is really interesting.
We've been following this.
We can call it a hypocrisy.
We can call it a double standard.
We can call it a contrast between the things
said on Fox News about vaccine mandates and
requirements and the policies of Fox News
as a company.
Now, most famously, Joe Biden said, Hey, we
need mandatory vaccine or test every week.
Fox News has done something even stricter,
and Fox News says mandatory vaccine or test
every day and wear masks around, wear masks
around others if you're not vaccinated.
And of course, people like Tucker Carlson
and the Fox and Friends, people and Jesse
Waters have just said, we don't have a mandate
here.
It's either not true, Fox and Friends said.
It's a protocol, not a mandate, et cetera.
OK, we now have leaked information from Fox
News's health and safety department as to
the requirements for their upcoming annual
meeting.
This is this is just amazing.
OK.
2021 FOX Annual Meeting of Stockholders.
Health and safety protocols.
Look at the rules.
Look at how strict this is.
First of all, if you have symptoms of COVID,
you got to stay home.
OK, fine.
They make that clear.
Health screening.
The designated stockholder entrance is at
particular address.
OK.
A prior to admittance.
You have to show your ticket to security and
you've got to participate in a health screening.
The health screening will have the following
components stockholders will be asked to complete
an in-person symptom screening and receive
a negative test result and present verification
that they are vaccinated.
Just to go to the stockholder meeting, you
got to bring proof of vaccine or acceptable
proof of a negative COVID test from 24 hours
prior from within 24 hours of going to the
Fox Studio lot.
This is much stricter than the US guidelines
for coming back to the U.S., which say the
tests can be from 72 hours before Fox says
24 hours.
Stricter.
And or you have to disclose your vaccination
status or any of them going to say our own
company is violating hip hop, which it's not.
Of course, if during the course of the health
screening process, a stockholder doesn't provide
verification that they are fully vaccinated
or proof of a negative test.
They will not be permitted entry and will
not be able to attend.
Period.
Following the health screening, stockholders
will be directed to the designated like, OK,
now look at this on the Fox studio lot.
Face coverings, all stockholders must wear
facial coverings while inside buildings at
all times.
Period on the Fox studio lot.
If you do not have a facial covering, a Fox
representative will provide a mask for you
at no cost.
Hand sanitizing, OK, they'll have hand sanitizer,
social distancing, facial coverings do not
replace the need for physical distancing,
maintain six feet from others when possible,
observe social distancing directives, etc.
At the annual meeting, stockholders should
sit in the designated seats and wear face
coverings at all times.
Breaks can be taken outside in the designated
area.
OK, so.
Fox News for their annual meeting.
Has a COVID health screening for everybody.
You either must be vaccinated or have a test
within 24 hours and you've got to wear a mask
the entire time.
And they're saying Biden's rules are authoritarian
now, of course, the people saying that on
air are not the people making these decisions.
But look at that contrast, and I think these
Fox hosts who continue to do this stuff and
say these things, they need to continually
be confronted with this when Tucker was confronted
with it.
He played stupid.
First, he said, I don't speak for Fox.
And of course, you could just speak as an
employee.
You don't have to speak as the people who
came up with the guidelines.
You can just speak as someone who is subject
to them.
And then he said, you know, you can't force
people to disclose their HIV status.
And it's like, Well, no, that's different
than than saying whether you are vaccinated,
saying whether you have a disease is different.
Also, HIV is not contagious and that it would
completely off the rails.
It was a really great exposition of how they
have no leg to stand on.
It needs to keep happening.
This is amazing that Fox is doing this.
I agree with all of it.
I mean, listen, you got a big stockholder
meeting.
You don't want it to be a superspreader event.
It's eminently reasonable, eminently reasonable
that this is what they are doing.
So check out the full document.
It's only like a page and a half two pages
for yourself.
Fox COVID guidelines for their annual shareholder
meeting.
OK, we've got a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David, P..
This is going to be a harsh voicemail yesterday
during a live stream of the first day of the
Kyle Rittenhouse murder trial.
I told my story of when I was on a jury, and
I explained that even for the minor assault
case that I was participating in the jury
for two thirds of the jury was incompetent.
They did not understand the simple instructions
from the judge.
They wanted to bring their own definitions
of things like self-defense and assault to
the jury.
And my point that I made yesterday was, listen,
there's a lot of incompetent people to put.
Former producer Louis, 80 to 90 percent of
people aren't good at their jobs, and it's
harsh.
And a lot of people get angry because if you're,
you know, OK, I understand it.